for boeing a fiery flight leads to
another plane grounding in a two-year
corporate spiral more than a hundred
boeing triple seven aircraft with a
specific type of pratt and whitney
engine
have been pulled out of service after an
exploding engine on united flight 328
over the skies of colorado
led to an emergency u-turn denver
departure united 328 heavy mayday
aircraft just to experience the
engine failure need a turn immediately
in the u.s federal
aviation regulators have demanded
stepped-up inspections of the engine
type that
rained down on a home a soccer pitch
and streets of colorado before the plane
landed
remarkably with no injuries inside or
outside of the plane
aviation experts blame hollow engine
blades that apparently broke off and
started the fire
it not only blew through the case and
blew through the cowling but actually
penetrated the fuselage damaging
the fuselage the wing and blowing out a
window causing a depressurization
that led boeing managers in chicago to
call for the global grounding of a
limited number of 777s that had been
flying
only from the u.s japan and south korea
the u.s federal aviation administration
is now investigating whether the fan
blades failed because they were damaged
and that damage went
undetected in routine inspection or
whether there was a manufacturing flaw
that led to the explosion
that could mean wider problems analysts
say this engine failure is less
catastrophic for boeing than the flight
control problems found to have caused
two crashes that killed 346 passengers
and grounded the then brand new 737 max
aircraft
for nearly two years it's just now
returning to service
this is the kind of thing which happens
from time to time with
highly stressed modern machinery
a fault which hadn't been detected
before suddenly makes itself
known and everything is frozen for a
while while an inspection takes place
to try and correct it this is not a
total systemic
fault like the max problem was still
after the grounding of a max plane that
was expected to be the company's most
lucrative
at a pandemic that's kept millions of
passengers on the ground
the 777's problems mark another black
eye for an already battered company
john hendren al jazeera chicago